Mind you, he's an ex-convict, ex-gang
member.
He literally sh in a bag on the outside
of his stomach. And his wife can smell
it in the middle of the night. His wife
can smell
in the middle of the night, and he can't
have kids. And you know what? I'm not a
young hoe. I'm not.
I'm old as hell, actually. What kind of
a dirt bag you have to be? Wallahi, what
kind of a filth you have to be?
We are teaching people how to pray.
>> And every time they pray, you get to
share in that reward.
>> And when they teach their children and
their children's children,
the reward continues. Every Fajr, Dhuhr,
Asr, Maghrib, Isha, every recitation,
for just £100,
>> you can help teach 20 to 60 people
>> like me learn how to pray salah. Donate
today.
As-salamu alaykum wa rahmatullahi wa
barakatuh, brothers and sisters and dear
friends. Hope you guys are doing well,
inshallah. Ramadan Mubarak. May Allah
subhanahu wa ta'ala accept our fasting
from every single one of us. See you
all, subhanallah.
Um so, I was
Oh, boy. It's Ramadan uh and we are
fasting, alhamdulillah. I'm not fasting
now, but I'm intentional of fasting
inshallah for the next day very soon.
And subhanallah, I came across this
video, and I saw it some videos
circulating about Akhi Ayman, etc.
Uh about the video where he's with
Sneako and I am one, etc. Who was he
with? And he said something which was
along the lines of uh which Let's watch
for ourselves, and then we'll come to
it, inshallah. But I don't like when
they say "Hijab is a journey." Shut your
mouth, man. The hijab is a journey. So,
what is it if it's not a journey? It's a
command from Allah. Mhm. Allah told you
to wear the hijab, wear it.
Don't just tell me I'm not ready. Say
that. I would rather you, as my sister,
my blood sister, telling me I am not
ready to wear the hijab. I said, "Oh,
no. No worries." Don't tell me it's a
journey, it's a struggle. Okay, so you
saw that for yourself. Now, when I saw
that, subhanallah, I'll be honest with
you, I was like,
it it doesn't look right. Yes, I know
the intention of what Akhi Ayman says
when it comes to this, but to me I was
like, "Ah, it's not right."
[clears throat] So, I messaged him. And
I messaged Akhi and I said, "Habibi,
give me some context. Is there context
behind it, etc.?" And here is my
message, which I'll show you guys,
because at the end of the day, listen,
we're not, you know, this girl code. You
know, with girls with a girl is girl,
you know, girl code. We don't roll like
that, bro. Akhi is my brother.
But if I'm wrong, Akhi will come to me
and say, "Habibi, you're wrong here." I
said, "Habibi, what's the message? I
mean, what's what's what's the context?"
Subhanallah. Okay. So, I said to him,
"Bro, what is the context?" So, he told
me a little thing and he said, "You know
what? Actually, I was maybe wrong the
tone, etc." Whatever. You know what I
said? The following. I said, "I hear
you, Akhi, but please try to be careful
what you say, cuz these lot looking for
your downfall at every opportunity."
Which it's true. I know what you mean
now, but it can come across as wrong
what you said. But no matter what, no
one should make slander against you. So,
I expressed my concern to him as a
brother. We didn't say brother code. We
call you back, Akhi, whatever you say,
"Yeah, bro." We don't work like that.
Our loyalties to Allah and His
messenger, not to my boy, not to anybody
else, etc. Alhamdulillah. Okay. Akhi is
doing a fantastic job when it comes to
the youth, taking people out of the
world who are trying to kill each other.
May Allah bless and preserve him. Here,
I believe, personally, I hear what his
message was, but it was delivered in a
wrong and it can come across wrong. So,
I sent that message to him. Okay, good.
Just imagine the people back in the day
when they would have to travel certain
distances for months or even years. What
is one thing that they would carry with
them?
The Quran. Why? Because they did not
have it on their mobile devices or their
gadgets. Brothers and sisters, imagine
you have a app, the Qurani app, which
not only shows you how much rewards you
get, but reminds you to read the Quran,
gives you reminders. Download the Qurani
app now and let it testify for you on
Yom Qiyamah that you read it wherever
you was. But before I get onto this and
go to a sick hidden field, wallahi, the
most disgusting person maybe I've ever
heard from a man in my life. This
nifaqis. They call them nifaqis. You
know, you have hijabis and niqabis,
these are nifaqis.
Before I get to her and what she said
that will blow your mind. Wallahi, it
would absolutely make you like go crazy
to your level. Subhanallah.
I want you guys sisters to also
understand this. Imagine a group of
sisters were together
and then they were talking about
brothers not lowering their gaze
or brothers beating their wives
or brothers doing gambling or brothers
not providing. And imagine one sister
came out and said, "You know what? But
lowering the gaze, oh, it's a journey.
>> [clears throat]
>> To hell with your to journey." And
somebody goes, "Your journey to hell."
Do you think that would be an uproar? Do
you think if somebody came and said,
"You know, and again look, I said
before, I'm I can be on the team and say
say, 'You know what? The way brother
Akim said it, a bit harsh and there was
no wisdom in it. No problem. I'm on your
team. Let's say. No problem.'" Now,
imagine somebody a sister came and said,
"Oh, gambling, spending your wife
family's money on gambling, yeah? Oh,
but I'm trying to stop it. It's a
journey."
Or alcohol or
or even even better, I'm making it even
better for everyone. Everyone all the
sisters can relate to it and it's halal.
Somebody might come and say, "Oh, you're
trying to equate beating a wife to this
job." No problem. No problem. How about
if a brother came and said, "It's a
journey that you know, I want to get a
second wife. It's polygamy. I'm trying
to stop my naf but it's a journey."
Argument's sake.
You guys would have a fit. You'd rip
your hijabs, your hair, your fake hair
or whatever you got you have etc. You
know, those fake hair do these that
everybody has. You would rip them all
out.
But when a man says something which I
can say,
"Okay, should have not been said in that
way." All hell breaks loose. Now, answer
this question. If a brother said that,
"I'm on my journey. I'm on a journey to
not get a second wife. I'm on my journey
to not gamble. I'm on my journey to
treat my wife right whatever." You guys
would have You would not say nothing.
Nobody would say nothing, bro. Okay? So
now, we're going to go to a video of a
big nose Nigerian. That's what she's
called by the way. Big nose Nigerian,
okay? That's her name on TikTok. That's
what she calls herself. Big nose
Nigerian, yeah? Let's see where her big
nose is getting into. Okay? She calls
herself big nose Nigerian. Let's see
where she's getting her nose into, which
is slander and harm. Look what she said.
You'll be mind-blown. Aki Ayman has been
weird since he got on this app talking
about how he broke all the mirror the
marriage stereotypes because he married
a black lady who had a child and who was
married before.
Yeah, so I don't understand. Yeah. It is
is is a lot of cultures have this
attitude. They're racist, whatever it is
for that matter. He did what's wrong
with that? We're not saying he did
like something like in the sense in this
community he's talking about or whatever
it is for that He's basically saying a
divorced sister who's maybe black.
There's There's people look down. There
are disgusting people out there. Aki and
he's trying to say that meant nothing
for him.
Yeah? And And that's the truth. And you,
he's a ex-convict, ex-gang member.
He literally shits in a bag on the
outside of his stomach and his wife can
smell it in the middle of the night. His
wife can smell his [__] in the middle of
the night and he can't have kids.
And to the sister who said you're
listening to a guy who literally shits
in a bag outside of his body,
>> [gasps]
>> Wallahi,
what kind of a dirt bag you have to be?
Wallahi, what kind of a filth you have
to be?
What kind of an Iblis you have to be
in Ramadan
in day like you're fasting?
You're fasting and you've got videos of
Ramadan you're talking about people
coming together etc. etc. You got other
videos where you're like, I can't say
the N-word, which we shouldn't say
anyways, because it's Ramadan.
But you are breaking your fast with the
flesh of your brother,
mocking his stabbing,
mocking his wife.
Yeah? Which you Nifaq is he for. Yes,
you go after people's wives. The The
other one which we're going to come to
in a minute. Yes?
Mocking the guy's wife. And saying he
because he's got a bag because of his
stabbing.
And you are mocking that.
It's Ramadan.
And believe me, I don't make duas
against people that easily. I can send
to the enemies of Islam. May Allah
subhanahu wa ta'ala deal with you and
expose you.
May Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala deal with
you and teach you a lesson you'll never
forget. I'll make a dua against you. The
fact that and wallahi wallahi if I saw a
brother mocking a sister who may have
something said something we don't like.
But to take this to a level as if
and you cross all limits.
I can already have been on the side and
say, "You know what? Delivery wrong. It
shouldn't have been said. No problem."
To go to a level
to slander the man.
To to Sorry, to mock him.
Insult his wife.
Insult his children. Wallahi, I fear
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala.
Wallahi, I would not even want this on
you. That Allah will make you crap
yourself without needing that bag.
Allah will make you that you are Let me
say something. Your husband is you're
probably married. Your husband probably
needs to smell that crap that's coming
out your mouth. Let me be honest with
you. He probably needs to smell this
rubbish when he's married to you. He
needs to marry like uh subhanallah. Yes?
The rubbish that's coming out your
mouth. May Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala
deal with you. Wallahi, I cannot believe
the filth of these nifaqis. The level
you're going You can disagree with me.
You can say, "You know what? He was
wrong to do that." To say something like
that is horrendous. Let's carry on. And
I'm not even trying to judge him. Oh,
and on Oh, just listen to me. So, before
that. Yeah? And then we've got We've got
the homewrecker we all know. The
homewrecker with the failed marriages
and, you know, the homewrecker who I
found out has got three failed
marriages, not two. Three failed
marriages. And people can have failed
marriages. It doesn't make that person a
thing. But the way this woman is moving,
audhubillah. Yes? I think there's a
common denominator. Yes? Three failed
marriages. Look at Ramadan. Who's a This
is another nifaqi. This is one Another
nifaqi saying what Check this out.
Wallahi, you guys will be absolutely
shocked. Yes? let's read it for
ourselves guys, yeah.
Misery loves company. So this this one
look what she goes.
Someone sent to me, both of them ability
to belittle a woman for struggling with
hijab when we heard the recording of him
being pressured by a woman who wasn't
his wife a couple of years ago. Stop
talking about woman and
focus on your journey. Okay.
And we know who we're talking about,
yeah? Okay. I mean it's the matter is
clear. Yeah, the one individual who
insults her mother and father who I look
people to me about her that she has a
sugar daddy. And the person knows that
Allah is my witness. When they came to
me I said listen, this can fall down as
slander.
I don't care if it's true or not. I
could have if I was petty then feel
Allah, I would have go out with this
evidence that I have. I said this is
slander. This is slander. Even though I
dislike her for the sake of Allah
nothing personal, leave this matter. I
said don't go near it cuz it's not
personal, man. It's nothing personal. In
Ramadan two Nifaqis, yes? One feeling
the worst of Allah. Okay, who wants to
wreck other people's lives. If you see
they always attack wives. Why are they
always going for other people's wives?
Cuz misery loves company. They hate
nothing more.
That's why when she shared that picture
of me and my wife she hated every second
of that. She hated that a man is serving
his wife while he's got the buggy on one
hand and the the left hand the child
while his wife is sipping a hot
chocolate. She could not deal with she
hates that. You know why? Cuz everything
she dreamt of was there.
And
>> [clears throat]
>> whatever happened to her. And now she's
now going for attacking another woman's
honor and they accuse her husband saying
that he was committing zina. Can you
imagine in Ramadan one is mocking his
stabbing, the other one is accusing of
committing zina with no evidence and
they're eating the flesh of their
brother.
The prophet walked past the grave and he
said these two are being punished for
nothing for something that great. One
for urinating on himself, the other one
for backbiting slander.
Backbiting and slander is a There's a
punishment of 80 lashes.
And they are casually in Ramadan. That's
why I call them nifaqis. They're not
niqabi or hijabi. Wallahi nifaqis. Why?
Mocking his stabbing and accusing a
married man of committing zina with
another woman.
Wallahi, alhamdulillah, Allah exposes
what kind of a filth nifaqis they are.
Nifaqis, five-star graded nifaqis. Let's
carry on the video, inshallah. And I'm
not even trying to judge him for his
past sins. What I'm trying to say is he
didn't even have the wherewithal to know
that she settled for him.
She settled for you, babe. But like,
someone who does not have the brain to
know that, why would he have the brain
to know that he job Wallahi, I believe
your husband settled for you. I would
never want to be married to a woman like
you. Audhubillah.
Mocking somebody else's stabbing. And
And his wife, wallahi, wallahi, wallahi,
if you was my wife, but you'll never be.
Wallahi, I would divorce you as as this
video. I say, "This is how evil you
are." Because he said something you
don't like. You can disagree. You can
come and say, "You are wrong. You
shouldn't No problem. It's your
opinion." You could have expressed it
100%. To go down the level and say he
craps in a bag and his wife smells it.
You are a scum. May Allah subhanahu wa
ta'ala deal with you and his
Please tell me, someone who does not
have the brain to know that his wife did
him a favor by marrying a man who shits
in a bag that is taped to the outside of
his stomach.
Why would he know that he job is a
journey?
Mhm? Allah's going to teach you a
lesson. I'm telling you.
But anyways, let's go. And this is the
same woman. This is the same woman. With
[__] I mean [__] people.
>> [music]
>> Oh lord. And this is her trying to say
it or not. She's trying to clean up her
vocabulary.
Sister, you fed the flesh of your
brother, his wife, subhanallah, and that
is bad you mocking his his illness.
The other one is saying that a married
man committed zina.
In the Sharia, they would take you in
public and whip you.
Wallahi al-Azim. Wallahi al-Azim, is
this the level that you you hate men? We
understand you have free for marriages.
We understand. You may be at fault,
maybe it's you.
The level of hatred she has for men.
Accusing she's actively trying to cause
people she's trying to ruin marriages.
Misery loves company. That's all I can
say. Wallahi al-Azim, misery loves
company. Why are you going for a man's
wife but accusing him of zina?
Yes, trying to put doubts in his wife's
mind.
Well, not that she has it. You are
actively she's actively trying She's a
home wrecker. That's the reason why I
called her a home wrecker. There's a
reason. There's a reason. And then not
only that, look at this she even refers
to herself as a h- I can't even repeat
it. Look how she goes. And you know
what? I'm not a young hoe.
I'm not.
I'm old as hell, actually. What do you
mean that you don't separate your whites
and your Look at this.
What Muslim woman calls herself a hoe?
Why would you call yourself a hoe?
Wallahi, when I saw this I said, you
know what, it makes sense. I don't know
why I ever had a great expectations from
you. Subhanallah. Okay. And wallahi,
brothers and sisters, wallahi, it's just
amazes me and shocks me the level
the level, wallahi. And subhanallah,
there's this other guy, I don't know who
he is, message, whatever it is, accusing
him of all he was on the road. Brother,
his friend Akhi in his own friend that
he greeted and turned his back stabbed
him.
You don't know, bro. What are you
talking about? When you trying to jump
on the bandwagon, are you trying to get
married? Are you trying to get brownie
points with the sisters? Just jumping on
the bandwagon for the sake of it?
You know not sure I'm going to say these
guys, wallahi.
I said it before as well. I believe the
tone
and I believe the way Akhi in his
passionate We get passionate sometimes,
okay?
But wallahi, if the opposite happened,
you guys would not have the same
reaction. If a sister come and said,
"Oh, if a brother said, 'Oh, I'm trying
to lower my gaze, it's a journey.'" None
of you guys would accept it. "Oh, you
know what, I've been mistreating my wife
recently right?
Right recently, but you know what? It's
a journey. Oh, you know what, bro? I
spent money on my kids' money on
gambling. It's a journey. Oh, I'm trying
to get a
second wife or five with my desires or
not to get a second wife, you know, it's
a journey to wallahi none of you guys
would buy it abadan. You would not.
Wallahi, let me tell you something. Not
only that, if a sister
mocked it, you guys would say, "Yep.
Go, girl."
That's what hypocrites you guys are. You
are hypocrites. When the truth came out,
yes, about this jahil home wrecker who
was accusing me of breaking a house.
Like what am I supposed to do? Yes,
okay. Someone who insults their own
parents. And the truth came out about AK
that her own brother accused her of
fornication. It wasn't going to do with
me.
No sister came out about it. Cuz you
know why? You know, and the fact that
that video of her mocking AK I came in
and his wife got 44,000 likes shows the
disease of feminism. And alhamdulillah,
I say sapients, subhanallah, and
alhamdulillah, we are now fighting this
disease of these nefaqis. They are
nefaqis
in hijabs and niqabs, but you know what?
Behind that hijab and that niqab is
nifaq. Nifaqis. That's what they are.
That's what they're going to be known
for. And alhamdulillah, we're going to
call them out. May Allah subhana wa
ta'ala deal with them that in Ramadan,
wallahi in Ramadan you're eating the
flesh of your brother and his wife. And
may Allah subhana wa ta'ala deal with
you guys. And for the home wrecker,
listen, misery loves company.
But let me tell you something. With this
kind of attitude, you're always going to
be miserable in your own company. Yep.
So, like I said before, don't be
jealous. Ask Allah for the same for
yourself. Change your ways. Inshallah
subhana wa ta'ala. I mean,
anyways, we'll make the matter clear,
inshallah. Till next time, brothers and
sisters. Assalamualaikum warahmatullahi
wabarakatuh. We are teaching people how
to pray.
>> And every time they pray, you get to
share in that reward. And when they
teach their children and their
children's children,
the reward continues. Every Fajr Zuhr
Asr Maghrib Isha Every recitation For
just £100 You can help teach 20 to 60
people
>> Like me Learn how to pray salah. Donate
today.